We could say many bad things about Russia,
but they have one very good thing that must
be recognized. If the golden rule of
any casino is "the dealer always wins",
in the energy game it is Russia that always wins.
It is by far the largest country
in the world and, what’s more,
its territory is full of natural resources,
which gives it a huge competitive advantage.
Just think of the world's fourth largest economy,
Germany. A lot of Volkswagens and a lot of
Siemens, but for decades Germany has depended
on Russian gas for abundant and cheap energy.
As you know, all this blew up with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine. And not surprisingly,
it has been very difficult
to find alternatives. One of
the biggest problems is Germany's
reluctance to use nuclear power.
Last April they shut down their last
three nuclear power plants. And of course,
there are many experts who stress that this
was a mistake, that nuclear energy could be
an alternative to natural gas and a way
to completely avoid dependence on Russia.
But wait a minute because we are
talking about energy. And in this game,
you know what we said, Russia always wins.
With 37 reactors, Russia is not only
the country in the world fourth on the
list for the most nuclear reactors. It
also dominates the nuclear fuel market.
You see, although its uranium mines account
for barely 5% of the planet's production,
Rosatom's global share in the uranium conversion
process rises to 27% and soars to 46% in terms
of uranium enrichment capacity.
This explains, as we told you here
on VisualPolitik last February, why
the West does not impose sanctions on
Russia's state-owned atomic energy corporation.
Now, just as LNG has offered the major alternative
to Russian gas, with nuclear fuel there is another
alternative, which is France: a country that has
a long nuclear tradition and could be an
important option for the West to consider
if it seeks to reduce dependence on Russia.
In Paris, they are clear about their strategy.
They want to proceed. But they have some stumbling
blocks to get past. The main one is that the
French nuclear sector has been in a permanent
crisis for 15 years. When it puts out one fire, it
immediately starts another. And the latest one has
been in a place as far away as it was unexpected.
(Niger coup sparks concerns about French,
EU uranium dependency – Politico)
Niger was the last democracy in the Sahel.
President Bazoum was considered by France
as an important ally in combating
the rise of jihadism in the region.
Now all indications are that things could change
completely with the new military junta in Niger.
The military constantly reproaches France for
its abuses as a former colonial power and accuses
France of meddling in its internal affairs.
So the question is: what does what is happening
in Niger have to do with the French strategy
to dominate the nuclear fuel market? What
does this strategy consist of? Is the West
going to continue buying enriched uranium
from Russia? Today on VisualPolitik we
are going to answer these questions.
But first... Did you have a clue
that the cost of certain online
products and services can fluctuate based
on where you're hanging out on the globe?
Travel firms, like airlines and hotels, adjust
prices based on the user's country. Therefore,
if you're in an area with higher
buying power than your desired spot,
be on guard! A UK study by NordVPN showed prices
can double, especially for vehicle rentals.
So, how do you sidestep these price disparities?
NordVPN, our sponsor today, masks your location,
letting you choose another. This allows you
to find the best deals for your getaway.
Furthermore, NordVPN gives you the chance
to soak up unlimited content from diverse
parts of the world, without any geographical
barriers. It's compatible with a multitude
of devices and allows you to link up
to six of them with a single account.
On top of that, NordVPN’s Threat
Protection feature will have your back,
operating in the background even when
you’re not hooked up to a VPN server.
So quit stalling, check out NordVPN
and get 4 months EXTRA on a 2-year plan
by going to nordvpn.com/vpen. And if
it doesn't quite hit the mark for you,
no worries: you've got a
30-day money-back guarantee.
(URANIUM FROM THE COLONIES)
Fifty years ago, the famous oil crisis occurred.
The price of dinosaur juice multiplied by four
after the Arab countries decided to
reduce their production. At that time,
most of the electricity in France, a country
with no oil fields of its own, was generated by
oil-fired power plants compared to 5% provided
by the first generation of nuclear reactors.
VisualPolitik viewers, this crisis was key to
the activation of the Messmer plan. In 1974,
Pierre Messmer, President
Pompidou's prime minister,
presented the plan by which France would end
its total energy dependence on foreign oil.
His goal was nothing less than to build dozens
of nuclear reactors. All it needed was uranium
for its nuclear fuel. And the French Atomic
Energy Commission already knew where to find it:
Somair and Cominak have for decades been two of
the largest uranium mines in the world. France
discovered uranium in Niger in 1957. So when this
African country gained its independence in 1960,
Paris ensured that it maintained priority access
to Niger's natural resources by means of a treaty.
And so, the large-scale exploitation of these
uranium mines started between the end
of the 1960s and the 1970s. There,
some French leaders were able to deploy all the
bad practices they had already used in Gabon.
You see, France began operating the Mounana
uranium mine in Gabon in 1960. In the late 1960s,
measurements recorded high levels
of gamma and alpha radiation among
mine workers. Adopting the radiation
protection protocols used in France
required costly investments and
the French were not in the mood.
The solution adopted was much more cost-effective:
tripling the thresholds above which radiation
exposure was considered dangerous to human health.
This is one of the advantages that the mines
in the former colonies had for France. Their
costs were much lower because neither the
safety nor the wages of the miners were the
same as in other countries. And at this point
I am sure that someone will be thinking: well,
if uranium mining has polluted a lot, at least
it will have left Niger with an economic benefit.
Well, no. The exploitation agreements
were abusively advantageous for France.
For many decades, French mining companies
paid only 5.5% of their revenues in taxes
to Niger. In Canada and Kazakhstan, where Orano
has been producing uranium since the late 1990s,
royalty rates are 13% and 18.5% respectively.
This has led to disparities as you can see in
this graph between the amount of uranium produced
and the revenue each country receives in return.
In 2014, a new agreement was
negotiated between Niger and Orano,
then called Areva. The royalty rate was
raised from 5.5% to a figure around 12%,
provided certain conditions of
profitability and uranium price were met.
Conditions have improved slightly,
but France has continued to operate
in Niger with a certain advantage
over the international market.
If we add to this the fact that Niger is
one of the poorest countries in the world,
we can surely speak of yet another case of
the resource curse. This is what economists
call it when they refer to a State that does
not benefit financially from the sale of its
resources. Even so, there is no greater
curse than the corruption of its leaders.
In 1974, Lieutenant Colonel Seyni Kountché
staged a coup d'état. President until 1987,
Kountché claimed to receive directly part
of the production of uranium oxide in a
percentage equal to the participation of the
State of Niger in the Nigerien subsidiaries
of the French mining companies.
A percentage of more than 30%.
In this way, Kountché wanted to sell
the uranium on his own account on the
international market. The atomic intentions
of his customers were not exactly peaceful:
Saddam Hussein's Iraq, Gaddafi's Libya,
Pakistan... Kountché is credited with
the phrase: "We will sell uranium
even to the devil if necessary".
Now I know what you are thinking. Since
the military junta that has seized power
in Niger is out for revenge against France,
they will surely break the agreements for the
exploitation of their mines, expel Orano
from the country and France will lose all
the uranium in Niger. And of course, considering
that nuclear power plants generate about 70% of
France's electricity, if Niger's military
suddenly cut off the supply of uranium,
France's energy production would surely tremble.
Right? Well, no. Unlike Germany with Russian gas,
this time France has done its
homework and done it very well.
France has been able to diversify its uranium
supply. According to data from the last 10 years,
the 88,200 tons of natural uranium imported
by France came mainly from three countries:
Kazakhstan (27%), Niger (20%) and
Uzbekistan (19%). Imports from
Australia and Namibia also stand out, with
14% in each case. In terms of annual data,
uranium from Niger never accounted for more than
35% of French imports in a single fiscal year.
These data are similar to those of Orano. In 2010,
Niger's mines provided two-thirds of its global
production. However, Niger now provides less
than one-third after the Cominak mine closed
in 2021. All this means that Niger's uranium,
once decisive, is now of relative importance
to the French energy system, accounting
for barely 20% of the uranium they import.
Compare that to the 60% that Russian gas
meant for Germany or even the 90% that
it meant for Eastern European countries like
the Czech Republic. In other words, if Niger
cuts off the uranium tap, France could easily
replace it with imports from other countries.
Now, that is not to say that the disruption
would have no effect. It would be a setback
for its strategy of being an alternative
to Russia in the nuclear fuel market. What
am I talking about? Stay tuned.
(A MARKET DOMINATED BY RUSSIA)
Just as combined cycle power plants use
natural gas as fuel to generate electricity,
nuclear power plants need their own fuel. The
process most commonly used in atomic power
plants to generate energy is nuclear fission.
For this they need an element that is fissile
or easily split. This is where uranium comes into
play. Now, just as you have to refine petroleum to
obtain fuels such as gasoline or diesel, you have
to enrich uranium to be able to use it as fuel in
nuclear power plants. The process is the same as
the one used to develop atomic bombs. What changes
is the level of enrichment needed. Take a look.
Natural uranium, as extracted from the mines,
is composed of 99.3% non-fissile
uranium 238 isotopes. The fissile part,
uranium-235 isotopes, accounts for only
0.7%. Enriched to between 3% and 5%,
this uranium serves as nuclear fuel for power
plants that generate electricity. Up to 20%,
enriched uranium is used to produce medical
isotopes, which are used in particular in the
diagnosis of certain cancers. Finally, to make
a bomb, enrichment must be brought up to 90%.
And guess what, right here is the key that has
led to the international nuclear fuel market
being dominated by Russia. Traditionally,
uranium has been enriched by two methods.
The West opted for the simpler one:
gaseous diffusion. Nevertheless,
this simpler method was very expensive,
since it requires a lot of energy to
enrich the uranium. How much energy are we
talking about? Well, to give you an idea,
the enrichment plant that France opened at the end
of the 1970s consumed 15 terawatt hours per year,
the same amount of electricity that would be used
today for public lighting in Paris for a century.
During the three decades it was in operation,
the Georges Bessee uranium enrichment plant
was France's largest consumer of electricity;
it devoured about 4% of France's entire
electricity production. In fact, at the height
of the Cold War, about 7% of total US electricity
generation was devoted to uranium enrichment,
for both military and civilian purposes.
Gaseous diffusion was the method used by the West.
Now, what were they doing on the
other side of the iron curtain?
Well, the Soviet nuclear program is known to all.
Both in terms of armament and atomic energy. The
USSR started up some thirty reactors. As for
uranium enrichment, the Soviet Union opted for a
more complex technique: centrifugation. However,
this method consumes 50 times less energy than
gaseous diffusion. This explains how today, in the
middle of 2023, we find news stories like this:
(Putin Still Selling U.S. Nearly $1
Billion in Nuclear Fuel – Newsweek)
When the Soviet Union fell in 1991,
the United States and the new Russia
agreed to what is popularly known as
the "megaton-to-megawatt program."
Highly enriched uranium from former Soviet nuclear
warheads was converted into low-enriched uranium
and shipped to the United States for use
in civilian plants. Also, given the cost
differential, Western electric utilities
rushed to acquire Russian enriched uranium.
In doing so they benefited from the more
cost-competitive technology of the Soviet era,
the problem is that at the same
time they contributed to the ruin
of those facilities in the West that
were still using gaseous diffusion.
But of course, in those happy 1990s, the
only thing in danger of running out under
Boris Yeltsin was our alcohol reserves.
So Russia achieved a position of market
dominance that has greatly benefited
Rosatom, the State corporation created
in 2007 by Vladimir Putin to be the Russian
giant in the global nuclear energy market.
A giant that is absolutely untouchable
even under the most adverse conditions.
(Pressure mounts on EU to sanction Rosatom
in next Russia sanctions package – Euroactiv)
Neither Brussels nor Washington has
dared to sanction Rosatom's nuclear fuel.
The United States stopped enriching
uranium years ago and about a third
of the nuclear fuel it currently uses is
imported from Russia, the world's largest
and also the cheapest producer. And yet the
bill rises each year to nearly $1 billion.
So, in the midst of the war in Ukraine,
with sanctions on oil, on natural gas and
on thousands of Russian companies and products,
it would be ideal not to depend on the Kremlin
for nuclear fuel. Right? Well, this is
where France's strategy comes into play.
(THE NUCLEAR ÉPOQUE)
VisualPolitik community, if you are
watching this video from Germany or Spain,
you may be surprised. But nuclear is all the rage.
Currently, 59 nuclear reactors are being built in
the world. These numbers are scheduled to increase
by another 111 in the next few years. In addition,
there are plans for another 321. Forty
percent of these reactors are or will
be located in China. But other powers such as
Russia and India are also investing heavily in
nuclear power. Even in the United States there
are serious plans to relaunch this industry.
And hold on a moment, because in Europe
there are countries that do not want to
be left behind. France already announced
before the war in Ukraine that it would
build six new reactors. But besides
those, the United Kingdom, Poland,
the Netherlands, Slovenia, Slovakia, the
Czech Republic, Hungary, Bulgaria, Romania,
Estonia and Lithuania also have nuclear power
among their plans. And it is possible that more
countries will join after the backing given
by the European Union to this technology.
(EU parliament backs labelling gas and
nuclear investments as green – Reuters)
The energy transition and the fight
against climate change will require
investment in new technologies. Also in
everything that involves maintaining our
quality of life while reducing
greenhouse gas emissions. It is
in this area that Brussels has decided that
renewables and nuclear must go hand in hand.
What’s more, the new modular reactors
are completely changing the reality
of this industry: they require much less
investment and can be built much faster.
For these reasons, European countries are ready
to give atomic energy another chance. They plan to
build new power plants and, of course, the most
important thing will be needed: nuclear fuel.
It will be necessary to increase
uranium production in the mines,
yes, but also to increase the
capacity to process that uranium,
convert it and enrich it. And this is
exactly where France wants to play a
leading role. It is already working on it,
as reflected in news headlines such as this:
(France Mulls New Uranium Plant to Cut
West's Reliance on Russia – Bloomberg)
According to an Orano spokesman, the French
state-owned company is considering two options: on
the one hand, building a uranium enrichment plant
in the United States; on the other, an option that
would be the quickest and most likely: expanding
by 50% the capacity of its modern Georges Besse
Two plant, operational since 2011 and already
enriching uranium using the centrifuge technique.
Enriched uranium is measured in SWU, separative
work units. At its Georges Besse Two plant,
France enriches 7.5 million SWU per year.
Increasing it by 50% would raise its capacity
to 11 million, whereas French nuclear power
plants currently need about 6.5 million SWU.
This corresponds to the approximately 8,000
tons of natural uranium that France needs for
its nuclear power plants. If it plans to produce
11 million SWU, it will need to import more than
13,000 tons of uranium each year. And this is
where Niger could create a problem for France.
As I was telling you earlier, its own energy
system can afford to do without the nearly
2,000 tons it imports every year from
Niger. It would find other suppliers.
But France does need this uranium for its
strategy of becoming a major exporter of
nuclear fuel and a real alternative
to Russian domination. In any case,
there is no doubt that Macron is working in this
direction. And that explains news items like this:
(Uranium from Mongolia interests France - LeMonde)
Macron and his foreign minister have
visited Mongolia in recent months.
There they have shown interest in making
investments worth about one billion euros
to get hold of Mongolia's uranium as well as
other metals such as lithium. Of course, in
Ulaanbaatar they have jumped at the opportunity
and have welcomed Macron with open arms. They
even say that France is the third neighbor
of Mongolia, that giant country wedged like
a sandwich between Russia and China. Along these
lines, a major agreement is expected very soon.
Of course, this does not detract from the fact
that, for the moment, France has a major headache
with Niger. Don't forget that the power that is
becoming strong in the Sahel is Russia, which
could suddenly find itself in Niger with a new
uranium supplier. Something that would undoubtedly
contribute to further consolidate its position
of dominance over the nuclear fuel market.
And this means that if the world
continues to bet on atomic energy,
we will all, including the West,
increase our dependence on Russia,
thus increasing the power of Putin and the
Kremlin. That at least seems to be Moscow's idea.
But, now the questions are over to you:
Do you think France will succeed in its strategy,
or will Russia always win in the energy game? You
can leave me your answer in the comments. In the
meantime, don't forget that we release new videos
every week so subscribe to VisualPolitik
so you don't miss any of our updates. If
you liked this video, LIKE it and see you in
the next one. All the best and see you soon.